so you guys just might have heard about
this new movie that's coming out next
year called The Avengers make I'm
personally looking forward to it I
really think they're going in a good
direction of this movie all the things
I've seen so far have really got me
pumped and feel like they're going
towards a really good place where they
can be in this place that is creative
but at the same time respects the source
material it makes the fans happy and I
really like that I already love the
established characters they've created
in previous films and I love the idea of
putting together lately there's been a
giant barrage of just new images that
have been released quite a bit character
photos I want to show you something
because they're really cool according to
a lot of photos release we see captain
america and thor teaming up quite a bit
in these photos now could you speed
they're filming one scene that where
they team up together or they might just
have a big part where they have to work
together in the movie so let's shot
through seen him captain america suit in
the past for the for the avengers it's
seen kat a cartoonish and really clean
and everything but here you know when
its dirty and grimy and cut up and
everything it looks really good we also
get some shots of Robert Downey jr. top
of everyone maybe character profile out
of hand we also have really good
character shot of jeremy renner and i
have a feeling he's gonna be like the ba
of the group the guy who like doesn't
take anything from anybody it just seems
the kind of guy who'd be like don't mess
with me man i will put an arrow in your
butt that sounded wrong and I really
like Mark Ruffalo but is it just me or
is he doing Magnum from Zoolander
there it is also we could have shut and
Nick Fury say what again look I love
Samuel Jackson I mean he's like he's one
of those actors who actually had more
time spell over he's all those actors
who actually has that benefit of him
just being on screen benefits it I mean
he doesn't even really have to do
anything terribly special if he's Samuel
Jackson and he's on screen he is special
I love samuel jackson also we've got a
Grilli nice look at scarlett johansson's
character which is very pleasing to the
eye I like redheads very much so what do
you guys think I personally think of the
Avengers going in a really good
direction I'm excited for it let me know
in the comments below we think of these
photos and i'll be back to you very soon
with a review for a machine gun preacher